[Music]
I'm here for the sensitivity training
and uh also do you have a better looking
sister please go inside and take a seat
the training will begin
shortly howdy cancel mates you want to
know why I got sent here nope incent
[Laughter]
exposure you all saw it right you want
to see it again
I could barely see it the first time
what I've seen brighter yeah well it's
not about the brightness it's about the
color temperature how about you what did
you do I was total BS some people
alleged I was verbally abusive and threw
food at my co-workers I mean a lot of
people actually that's ridiculous you're
obviously not the type to waste food you
should talk you family-sized bucket of L
ass ow that hurt in more ways than one
it hurt in two
[Music]
ways